well i've even noticed a difference in
like when i would make the
because the problem is like you know
these places had a boogie man
and a lot of them were willing to be um
unprofitable i mean these ones were
talking about that
revived them but there were some places
you know like you know corporations that
were still willing to like take the hit
and almost go unprofessional
bro and it's a little harder to do that
without the boogeyman i've even noticed
with my videos
you know if people would before like
originally when you laugh at something
you'd be like is this funny where now
you go
is it on the right side okay now i can
decide whether to laugh i don't do that
i just i laugh
yeah i don't think the moment did that
but a lot of people do yeah i've got a i
got a a picture
downstairs of uh uh donald trump and
he's like he's like a little tiny person
dude and he's like he's got his hands
behind his back it's from george
oxopolis and the and the the
director is signed they're like uh no
it's a comic and they're like
mr trump are you ready to win tonight's
debate and then he they lift him up and
he's really small and they put him into
a mech suit
and like steam comes out then he
straightens his time and he goes bigly
like you can make fun of trump if it's
you make if you're actually making fun
of him
like drawing a fat sad trump with tiny
hands is not a joke it's
like it's just a tribal signal it's like
hey i'm i'm like you
look the thing you make an actual funny
joke about trump they love it
there's like like trump makes makes fun
of himself and even trump's reporters
love it when he's self-deprecating
because
he owns it you know what i mean on the
left
it's am i on the right side is the joke
allowed well there's two parts of it
like the fur
for the first part like i said i've
noticed that people
have lost that a little bit they'll
they'll just laugh first because they're
like
it's it's a little better because they
feel like they won the no but some
people
that feel like they've won now that
trump's gone i'm noticing them sort of
being like
oh i can just laugh i can laugh again
like they've all they almost feel like
that but the second part
the difference between like the right
and the left humor is
when you talk about you know things that
were you know
crazy jokes that when they talk about
like even censorship like crazy jokes on
the right crazy jokes on the left
things that you're like not okay with
the difference is when you're talking
about the right it's like a guy yelling
it on bit shoot for like 40 people to
hear
when it's on the left it's like this is
netflix special yeah or like
you know dove soap or whatever right so
i think that's why one's
a little more aggressive institutional
power versus some random guy
and you know what i think too it's it's
what we're seeing with trump i think
we i think trump sort of jumped in front
of everybody
to like as the bolt was being fired in a
figurative sense
because the media has been going after
small random internet people for a
really really long time
just like some random guy in bit shoot
will be like here's my rant and they're
gonna be like [ __ ] shoot is hosting
extremists they should be shut down and
it's like
dude the guy's got like 40 views leave
them alone you know where else are they
gonna go yeah but then
they use institutional power and it's
basically like
they made a demand hey this is racist
and then everyone said okay you got it
well that's racist too you got it and
they just keep going and it's like
they're just
literally hammering whatever they can
find any tiny
smidgen of of offense so they're chasing
it to the darkest corners of the web and
then screaming about at the top of their
lungs yeah which is how you get rid of
racism actually yeah
that's how you do it i mean honestly
when you put the bad kids all in one
class that usually sorts it out
right now they they probably think that
they're chasing it down and destroying
it and it's like
they just don't want to hear it it's
like they think a lot of these people
feel like it was war right and if you
think about that and you're like at war
and imagine i'm there like trying to
make jokes about our general like
we're about to go kill these people and
i'm like general's a little looking a
little sleepy today right and everyone's
like dude we're about to go like try to
kill these people like
not the time and i'm like yeah but like
check it out like
bad bands and no no one wants to hear
any jokes right right but if i was to be
like look at their general like i can
barely speak everyone be like
you just described what michael mouse
was explaining the other day on the show
about the soviet union wow where he said
that you know uh some american was
explained you could go into the oval
office
pound on reagan's desk and say i think
reagan is doing a terrible job
and then the soviet guy was like oh you
can do the same thing in the soviet
union you go to the red square yeah hang
at the table
i think ronald reagan is doing a
terrible job actually yeah that's that's
that's
is it kind of weird that we're comparing
the soviet union to these people or
these people to the soviet union
no yeah it's not weird at all it's scary
it all like yeah and it all boils down
to kind of the
you know what you think the purpose of
comedy or what but they want to collect
all these properties right it's like we
need to collect music and i think it was
music's a little easier of a cell
because if you're a singer and they go
okay you can't sing about this and you
go uh whatever the music these lyrics
are one
part of it but really it's like my songs
are still the same and i can kind of be
all with the ball and um
yeah i'm pretty sure they'll figure it
out do you know what i mean so but with
comedy unfortunately like you're
speaking so i think comedy
gave itself up a little easier little
harder so they had a harder time
collecting that property
right where they collected the
universities they collected music they
collected advertising
and i think comedy was a little harder
for them to scoop up which is why it
became such a contentious issue
comedy is one of the most powerful tools
in opposing authoritarianism that's why
they
they they hate it and it's so hard for
them to conquer
if they want their you know lockdown or
whatever
comedy is making fun of things all the
time
and it depowers a lot of this stuff
right it takes power away it
ridicules it makes it seem weaker in a
sense that's why making fun of things
works so they need that if they if you
have
a top-down authoritarian culture what's
the one thing
everyone can get if you tell a joke so
like you're in you know the soviet union
and everyone has a problem with hot
water
and you make a joke about hot water
because it's relatable to everybody and
i'll laugh
they get mad at you because they're like
you're criticizing
us and the authority in the system
they're not i don't i don't see how
they're gonna be able to get through
you know like this wokeness i don't see
how it gets past the constitution
well it doesn't but the demands the
demands on
certain levels of speech are too
debilitating like i said like there's
certain things you go hey if you're
gonna run a company you run ads you got
to say this and they go okay whatever it
doesn't really change us fundamentally
we're selling t-shirts or whatever
but if you say this about comedy which
is essentially
noticing trends or you know noticing
sociological
you know let's say i noticed that one
group does this and one group does this
and they go
yeah but you're not allowed to do that
anymore so it's like the demands on
you know speech-oriented fields like
what you do of talking four hours a day
or whatever
like all these demands are like
debilitating to what you're doing so
it's that's why it's like harder for
them to collect those
which is why those are always the
linchpins that they try to take care of
right
whenever like authoritarianism comes
down it's like always
first we want to get rid of like jokes
about the wrong things and we want to
get rid of
observations about the wrong things yep
and they're trying but i don't know if
it i don't i don't i don't know if it
can work so you want to make it illegal
to notice things
no but for real because you can do
comedy without even
like you can deliver a comedy without
acting or you know doing a bit in a
sense
when you when you think about a joke
it's like someone is telling you a joke
you know they are
you can literally make people laugh by
just talking about normal things
and so you can have an idea so then they
need to control the ideas themselves
and that's probably a part of what
cancer culture is it's it's like
psychological terrorism will destroy
your life if you step on the wrong twig
that's why i was saying it's like the
the silent hill nurses
as soon as you make a noise they just go
wild and start swinging like crazy
if you're who would want to be in with
these people why would you want to be in
these universities
it's like you're walking down the
hallway and then you're like sweating
and you're looking around and then you
step on a twig and you go oh geez and
then they all go
and they're like jump out of the walls
and they're like latching on you're like
ah
i always leave i'll leave i don't want
to be there i'll just
or i'll purposely throw the twig you
know throw rocks well that's the room so
they'll go
you hit the nail on the head like when
you make the equations of how these
operate there is like an equation that
involves
how not okay it is to say right so
that's
a lot of times you know if you go oh you
this is the thing you can't say you just
made it like super funny right
so right it's like they're also involved
in the equation
it's kind of like that idea of like like
the fat gross thing jokey has made it's
like the fat gross joke yeah yeah yes
that all of your moms listen
you said is that would you what do you
say she's a huge surprise yeah
queen so you wouldn't normally say that
until they
made it about no it wouldn't be funny
yeah right now it's only funny because
it's like pointing naughty i mean yeah
lack of a better word
naughty i mean it's like it's adorable
yeah yeah transgressive yeah offensive i
mean listen if you if you were in
let's say saudi arabia and they go the
the one guy you can't talk about is this
like if you were 10 years old and you're
like that goes you know you make a
little joke about that guy that's
the funniest person to make a joke about
well yeah of course how is family guy
still on the air
because i know that they've changed it
they announced like a couple years ago
they wouldn't do gay jokes anymore
so they've certainly changed it they're
not going to do jokes that are gay or
both both we have a system in the
writing room if anyone says oh that's
gay then we don't do it we're on the but
that's it yeah
no game but dude you watch the old
episodes and i'm like
they there was a joke we were just
watching a rerun and
peter said something about you know the
callback jokes
and he was like that was like the time
that out that you know that i was
helping the band huey lewis and the jews
and then the guy you know the song we
don't need money and then the
members go we quit and they walk out
like that joke is
like by today's standards could you tell
that joke like that's a can that's
cancelable but it's on tv every day on
numerous channels well i think you know
people always just make their changes
like
a lot of people kind of the same way
that people are moving to different
places right now with the kovid
people are making their changes and if
you look around you know people like you
have started their own thing
and everyone's kind of been making moves
based on you know what they say you can
and what you can't do but
i do all those jokes in comedy clubs
yeah you know i say aggressive stuff but
there's that rung where youtube's gonna
be like you're done
i guess the issue is is the mob gonna
notice you
because what'll happen is these clubs
are probably gonna be like hey man look
i don't think there's any
anything wrong with your jokes i just
can't afford it if they come and start
throwing stuff you know what i mean
it is what do you do what do you like so
you know you you performed at a bunch of
clubs yeah
yeah and you know the managers are the
owners yeah you're like cool with them
what if one of them came to and said
dude i don't want to cancel you but like
they're our phones ringing off the hook
they're threatening our patrons like
we can't have this man what do we do i
think a lot of
comedy club owners will will will stand
up for that
yeah so i mean that's what you know that
happened like ari shafir and they called
like 150 people called when he did like
the kobe joke and people went crazy
and the people at the stand were like
they're like they just forward them
they'd be like it's hilarious
i mean i'm on the show but what are you
gonna do it's a comedy club like it's
just press but
it's not that it's like they'll take
your tv shows away they'll take all that
stuff but if you're
in the comedy club is like the one place
it's hard for them to take except for
like a very
few things yeah this is the the bigger
issue i think is like people
i i guess people might assume it's more
nefarious in a lot of ways like i'm sure
even when it comes to tvs getting tv
shows getting canceled something like
that
the dude who's like at the network isn't
going like how dare you say that we're
banning you he's probably going like
i'm really sorry this is happening man
but our sponsors are pulling out we have
we're losing
money what what do we do and then it's
like
sorry you're you're out because we're
losing money mcfarland's part of the
cult
of uh biden or anti-trump so that's why
they haven't knocked
family guys really low information guy
like a lot of these people
but i'm not trying to be mean but like
something happened where in
there was a period where like seth
macfarlane knew stuff
like you know you know he has a family
guy joke where stewie's running naked
through the mall going i just escaped
from kevin spacey's basement
and then there he made a joke about
harvey weinstein so people were always
making the joke like what did seth
macfarlane know cause apparently he was
supposed to be on a plane he doesn't
write the show himself
right right right so sam let me tell you
how the tv writing room happened
you walk in and say my name's on the
show get to work i'm gonna
grab lunch hey can you guys work any
harder the homer simpson style
yeah yeah uh seth macfarlane wasn't he
supposed to be on a plane on 911
and then he like didn't get on the plane
yeah i bought him the ticket but then it
didn't work out
there's like there's like a no there's
like a conspiracy about like what he
actually knows and who he's connected to
but i think i i think there was a period
where you know people like bill maher
and uh and people accept mcfarland knew
stuff
they knew it was going on and they knew
better than a lot of people and so they
were able to make jokes that were
topical and funny and they could make
good points
and then at some point they just totally
gave up
and now they just like it's it's
remarkable how behind the times bill
maher is for instance i think everyone
you know it's very hard to be 55 and
like crazy
in the pulse so i think that's just the
same way that you probably aren't on the
same pulse about what the new music
is i think culturally oh the new music
it's this great song
by tim poole it's the one yeah it's true
it's the newest it's the best so what's
the
i like this song like the video there i
i i think support my upcoming artists i
agree
that's right i agree but it's it is 14
plays on soundcloud
it's it's not about what the new music
is because there's certainly new music
that i would listen to
that a 15 year old wouldn't it's about
you might not know what
gen z is doing with tic toc and the
songs they like yeah but that's just
their community
so you have yours when it comes to news
about being factually correct
and i think right i'll tell you this is
phenomenon that we see in skateboarding
that we've all like me and like all
skateboarders know this
amateur skateboarders it doesn't mean
like it doesn't mean what people think
it means it means quite literally you're
paid to skate you don't have your own
signature model
amateur skateboarders are insanely good
like some of the best skateboarders in
the world
once they sign that pro contract their
skill level drops substantially you know
why
because they don't got to do it anymore
they're right well they don't stop but
it's like
if you want to don't go grind like that
that's i mean comedy is the exact same
way
yeah once you get the show you're
comfortable you're going to chill out i
mean
the truth is comedy sucks to do i mean
even in covid
so when you stop doing it and you know
lived like three months of like not
really doing stand-up you're like
oh this is way better yeah i mean why
would anyone do this
so it sounds like it would be fun well i
mean you say that but
like the idea of you know leaving every
night doing writing two hours then you
do four shows a night it's the same as
it's the same as anything right like
training to be like a professional
athlete
sucks you know if you want to be in the
gym five hours a day and then doing wind
sprints like
you take days off like if you're like oh
you need to take a month off that you're
like yeah no this is better that sucks
to do
so it's a very hard life but you want to
be the best and it's not
to me it's irrelevant i hear what you're
saying because you're telling the same
jokes
like four times a day right i was acting
in hollywood while but it was like up at
4 a.m you'd work till 6 p.m
and you got paid so much money but it
was so exhausting no no but
what i mean is if you're doing four
shows a night you're doing the same set
for the most part right
well i mean i have a system i mean i
would write and then i would write
two hours in the morning and then i
would do news then like my newest 10
minutes then and then i would chisel
that down for the sex show and then i
would chisel down by
and then the end of the show i'd have
maybe a new like 20 seconds then the
next day i'd do the exact same thing and
then everything's repetitive
you're doing the same thing well it's
you've got to make it sound fresh
like you're just saying it depends yeah
it's whatever it doesn't even matter
it's the equivalent of you could say
that like a a runner or like a
weightlifter is like doing the exact
same thing but you're kind of
tweaking it and it's a little different
it depends on how you look at you know
training you know what makes this job
easy for me
even though i do like four hours of
talking a day is that i'm saying
something different
plus you're sitting at home you don't
have to go to these junkies no that's my
worst
part loud dark bars cold staying at home
is actually the worst
i disagree that's what works what what
makes it the same and boring is that
it's just literally here
all day every day right what makes it
about doable is that it's a different
story something's changed something's
happening here's what i think is going
on it makes it really easy to do
just you know every day but when you
really want something i think none of
that matters like all that matters to me
was like at the end of that week did i
have like a new two minutes is great
well do you have this new joke like how
does this
that's you know so all if that's the
most important thing then who cares
about all the other stuff i mean
you sound like a guy i mean you've even
talked about this before that when you
were younger you're like i wanted to be
a journalist and you were willing to oh
i didn't well the way
when remember you said well this is what
you told this is what you said that you
like you know put your own money in
you've sent yourself overseas you like
you started doing stories crack am i
right now when i was a little kid
when you're a little kid when you're
what did i say when you're younger when
i was 26 and started doing this it
wasn't so much about being journalists
because i had no no aspirations for
journalism or anything like that it was
about traveling
traveling seeing stuff and then talking
about it which is basically you know
it's
part journalism well it sounds like you
decided that you're going to do
something and you're
i decided i was like dude it'd be really
cool to fly to spain and see what's
going on heck yeah
people love traveling and seeing stuff i
mean i could give the press answer of
comedy where you're like
so what is it like and i'm like i don't
know dude i just get up there have a
couple beers or whatever
that definitely sounds cool you know
there is a thing where i'm always like
why do i do this because it is so much
easier to be like i don't know dude i
just tell some jokes it sounds so much
cooler but what's the alternative do you
just like
not work sit around and play video games
or what what could i do i mean make
videos podcasts i mean be in tv shows
like there's a million things oh yeah i
just mean stand up through that
well i mean it's what you said yeah it's
the exact same thing you said it's like
when you're skateboarding there's a
million things you could do in the
skateboard community
but like spending five hours a day like
perfecting one trick like yeah that
is the hard part the easy part is going
and making commercials
doing you know endorsement deals like
hanging out doing interviews whatever
all that stuff
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you